Well, welcome everybody to another Zoom column.
That's this jump in.
We get started.
Those there do.
If you think of a question as we're going or you didn't get the question submitted
to the Zoom page or the member site, then go ahead and chat.
Put it in the chat and we'll get to that.
Just a couple minutes after we get through the ones that are submitted.
Always check the member site for new updates.
There is a new update today.
We will not have a Zoom call next week.
I'll be out of town.
So no Zoom call next Wednesday.
It's all over the announcements.
This is a little picture here.
So you'll see that in the member site.
So there's never any new announcements.
We try to get them up on the member site or any new changes or anything you need to know.
Okay, for the first question.
Let's jump right in.
I have both a true rife end and a tell you a ramen rife machine.
Are the computers slash programs interchangeable?
No, no, they're not.
So they're different.
You cannot run true rife programs on the until you're ramen.
No, or could you definitely cannot run until you're ramen programs on the true rife?
So no, they're not interchangeable.
So you can't change computers and run a true rife program on your until you're ramen vice versa.
How about the foot bath pieces that I had pro-wave?
Well, that the until you're ramen will invite actually fit into that thing.
But you're going to you do not do that.
So they're not interchangeable.
The only thing that would be interchangeable would be the bulbs.
So the bulbs are interchangeable.
That's the only thing that would be interchangeable.
So something happened to your true rife bulb.
You could use the one that came with your until you're ramen with the true rife.
That's the only thing that would be interchangeable.
Next question.
Is it safe or a cancer patient to drink out of copper cups?
I've seen a lot about using copper and copper cups.
I imagine it as a natural antimacterial.
No, the answer is no, it's not.
No, where do I think it's safe for a none cancer patient to drink out of copper cups?
So the copper that one would receive if you drink out of copper cups.
What type of copper are you getting?
First of all, you're not going to leach much copper if you're drinking cold water out of a copper cup.
It's really not going to leach much copper at all.
In fact, you could measure a lot of people have copper pipes in their house.
But if you measure the amount of copper that is in the water, it's pretty slim.
Now, in the hot water pipes, if you have copper pipes, you might have a higher amount of copper in that water.
And I don't want anybody to go and change their pipes in their house.
The copper, the type of copper that you would receive if you, if the copper leached off of the cup into the water.
As an iod would be an elemental copper that is not readily absorbed.
So again, your minerals that you receive the periodic table of elements copper is there.
So as iod people would also use this same argument to trick to use iron cookware.
I'm going to use my cast iron pan because I'm getting iron from my cast iron pan.
Well, you're probably getting more iron from your cast iron pan than copper from your copper cup.
Because you're heating your cast iron pan.
So you're probably getting more leeching of the iron into your food from the cast iron pan.
But you don't use a cast iron pan to get that iron, that elemental iron that you'd give from a cast iron pan.
And the elemental copper that you give from a copper cup is not readily absorbable.
That's not how we're supposed to be getting our minerals.
That's like saying I'm going to go out and eat some dirt this afternoon.
I'm going to just go down to my garden and take a big handful of dirt and eat that because I need some minerals.
So I'm going to eat dirt.
Matter of fact, there's a condition in children that's called pica.
Pica is from a Latin order that means dirt eater.
And children will bring dirt and eat dirt out of houseplants when they're mineral deficient.
However, they're not getting much mineral out of dirt.
Again, we're not supposed to eat dirt.
Plants eat dirt.
And then they change the minerals in the dirt.
So there's minerals in soil.
So you're the plants take the minerals from the soil and convert it into a different form.
It's a double bonded to typically a glycine or another amino acid.
And then we eat plants or your herbivore cow eats that plant.
And then it has minerals in the muscle.
So you could get minerals from eating a good grass fed cows.
You could get minerals from eating your vegetables.
But we don't get minerals from eating dirt.
Nor do we get minerals from eating drinking out of copper cups.
Nor do we get minerals from eating out of cast-iron pans.
Those would be elemental minerals.
And they would not be readily absorbed.
And if they are absorbed, they're not going to be readily available to be transported into cells.
They can cause havoc.
So I am not a fan of some of these Instagram posts.
I'm sure this is where you're not this.
There's a lot of even doctors out there that are saying we should be drinking out of copper cups.
Because copper is good for us.
Well, first of all, cancer patients do not want excess copper because copper, as a mineral,
got received the right way through plants in a double bonded amino acid form.
Is necessary for our body as so many trace minerals are.
But what it does is it stimulates growth.
So cancer patients, I don't want cancer patients to take supplements with copper in them anyway.
And again, the form of copper that you'd get from a piece of copper would not be the right form.
Good lead to excess copper.
You could have genetic issues where it causes more problems with excess copper.
Because you don't transport copper very well.
And copper toxicity is extremely common.
So that's why I rather have a person be taking zinc because zinc will push out excess copper.
There's a delicate balance between zinc and copper.
And many times because people are zinc deficient, they'll store more copper.
Copper toxicity can lead to muscle aches and pains and arthritic problems and brain disorders.
All sorts of things from copper toxicity.
It's very, very covered.
And it could be a big issue.
So the whole thing about drinking out of copper cups and eating out of cast iron.
We use cast iron, but I don't use it to get ironed.
And I don't use copper cups because we don't need elemental copper.
I don't think you're getting much on of it.
You got to remember there's lots of ridiculous fans out there that have no basis of human physiology.
But natural doctors jump on the bandwagon of these things.
Kind of foolishly and make themselves out to be deep thinkers sometimes.
And I've been guilty of that too.
We have to be careful of what we're pushing.
We got to really think about it from a metabolic physiological standpoint.
Does that make sense?
So the answer is no.
I would not do that.
Next question.
My husband has a bladder cancer.
And he has been treated with BCG, which is a type of needle therapy for bladder cancer.
And has had them scraped off, the tumor scraped off.
I assume before, but they keep coming back.
They are not in the muscle, so they're not called deep.
So they're just in the epithelial layer on the inside of the bladder, which is the lighting.
Is there something to do to prevent them from coming back?
So this question was asked by a person that I haven't spoken to for a long time.
But originally, I think the person's cancer that we programmed the right for was not bladder cancer.
So definitely, I would check on that if I would have a call with me so that we can make sure that we're running the right program.
And so number one, we would want to run specific programming for bladder cancer and get some more details.
If this has been has been diagnosed as transitional cell carcinoma.
That's a type of common bladder cancer.
We'd want to get that detail.
So from a from a rife setting program, we'd want to be running the right frequencies.
Number two, we'd want to be doing something very specific for this cancer.
So I can't really say, oh, you should take this supplement, this supplement, or this supplement without testing.
So we really should do it on a cheek swam test too.
Next question, what is the best way to increase my platelet numbers?
So from a natural perspective to increase, first of all, take a step back.
Always, we want to know why something.
So if I have low platelets on my blood test, we want to investigate why.
It's not uncommon for a person with cancer to have decreased platelet numbers.
So the cancer could be that it's very common for different cancer drugs to decrease platelet numbers.
So, you know, we'd have to look at that.
So we'd want to find the reason why first.
But let's say the reason why is not really something we can change.
Let's say it's because of a medication that I have to be on or whatever.
Some natural ways to increase platelet numbers.
Well, red meat could help with platelet numbers.
Vegetables can help with platelet numbers.
Fruit could help with platelet numbers.
So there's a lot of different foods that can help benefit platelet numbers.
Many times people have low platelets because they're not eating enough protein.
They're not eating enough food.
They have some decreased red blood cell code.
Hemoglobin have adequate and low platelet code partially because they're not consuming enough food.
It's very common with people as they age.
And it's very common with people with, you know, cancer, especially stage three or stage four cancer.
So we want to make sure that we're eating enough meat because that protein content is not going to only help increase our red blood cell code.
They have adequate platelet numbers, but it will also give us the ability to make the white blood cells necessary.
The T cells and the natural killer cells to help kill cancer.
And unfortunately, many times we're not feeling well, we don't eat.
So we want to make sure our protein content is up as well.
Next question I've heard a lot about the negative impacts of oxalates.
Should we be watching our oxalate intake?
First of all, can oxalates cause health problems?
Yes, so what are oxalates?
It's a type of biochemical that's found in different foods.
Like rhubarb has a lot of oxalates.
Green leafy vegetables have a lot of oxalates.
Spinach has a lot of oxalates.
Kale has a lot of oxalates.
Well, should we stay away from oxalates because I heard that oxalates can be bad?
Well, they can be bad for some people.
So there are in your genetic summary, some people have defects on their genes that help produce enzymes to get rid of oxalates.
Those people have a much greater chance of having negative impacts of oxalates.
Many of the stones, the kidney stones and even some gallstones can be oxalate based stones.
So typically people that are prone to kidney stones or gallstones or even liver stones are people that have defects on those oxalate genes.
And if that was your case, I would have told you that you should limit oxalates because you have defects on those genes.
To be honest, it's not at least what we have seen in the population of cancer that we see.
I haven't seen very many people with oxalate genetic oxalate issues.
It doesn't mean that it doesn't exist.
I just, it's not as common.
Maybe it's not as common with some people with cancer.
I don't know.
So it's, I don't see this a lot.
But so oxalates, having issues with oxalates are not a food sensitivity per se.
It's, it is that you don't get rid of them well.
You're not binding them well.
Typically oxalates would be bound in the gut and you wouldn't absorb very many of them.
But people could have genetic defects where they don't buy oxalates.
They absorb and they have excess oxalates and then they end up having issues.
You can see this also on the organic acid test.
Well, if people have oxalate issues, it will always show up there.
And then the genetic test.
But when I say that because I saw a video about the negative impact of oxalates that I'm going to really go on to oxalate free diet, no, I would not do that.
There's all sorts of chemicals in different foods that can be a problem for some people.
But it's usually a small percentage of the population that have that issue and then they have to be careful with that.
Next question.
Could you tell me again why a cancer patient should not take glutamine?
My other doctor wants me to take it for my gut.
Well, this is a kind of a caution for taking advice from too many people sometimes because sometimes another doctor is not necessarily trained in taking care of cancer patients.
So this is why I also ask you you're free to do whatever you want, you know, as far as supplements that you feel like you want to take or boy, the other doctors and getting their advice by all means go ahead and do all that.
But, you know, I think it's a good idea to run it by me like this person did by asking me this question.
My other doctor wants me to take glutamine and I think I remember you saying it's not a good idea.
Well, the reason why it's typically not a good idea is because cancer is always trying to find a source of fuel.
The first source of fuel for every cancer is going to be sugar breaks down into glucose.
Glucose is going to be the main source of fuel because it is always the main source of fuel for all cells.
Glutamine is another secondary source of fuel for all cells on brain cells.
Glutamine can be primary source of fuel for certain brain cells, especially astrocytes.
In your brain can be fueled by cancer.
So certain brain cancers, especially astrocytoma and another possibility is of glioblastoma, are can be fueled by glutamine.
So you have to be careful under glutamine intake.
So why would a person take glutamine?
Why would you be recommended glutamine for the gut?
Because glutamine can help the help replenish and heal epithelial cells quite quickly because it really upregulates the growth of and reproduction of epithelial cells.
Now if you have a cancer, do you want something that's going to fuel growth?
Not such a good idea.
So I wouldn't take glutamine as a supplement to help heal the gut.
There's a lot of other choices out there.
So there's a lot of different supplements that you could do to help heal the gut without having to take glutamine.
So that's why I wouldn't do it.
Is that it upregulates growth?
Next question, I used to take curcumin, but it really bothered me.
Is that a genetic problem?
No, there's not too by knowledge that there is any genetic issue with curcumin.
So a person isn't genetically sensitive to curcumin.
But curcumin is a food and a person can develop antibodies to curcumin.
So you could develop antibodies to anything.
So if you develop antibodies to curcumin, then every time you take curcumin,
you're creating an inflammatory reaction.
So if you have antibodies to curcumin, IgA or IgG antibodies to curcumin,
every time you eat it within zero to 20 hours, you're going to have an inflammatory response.
And how high your antibody level is to curcumin.
This would be true if you had antibodies to gluten or dairy or asparagus or any other food.
If you have antibodies to a food and you consume that food,
you're creating this inflammatory response, basically a fire in the gut in the body,
and you could have systemic inflammation.
And we'll make a comment like, I can't take curcumin because it just bothers me so much.
They probably have antibodies to it.
Now, I will say that the antibodies to many foods will dissipate over time.
So let's say I used to take curcumin 10 years ago, but it really bothered my stomach,
so I stopped taking it.
By all means, you could try taking it again because usually if you stay away from a food,
and gluten is the only exception, gluten and dairy really are two main exceptions for that.
But if you stay away from the food that you have antibodies against,
many times those antibodies will dissipate over the course of three to six to nine months.
You really stay away from curcumin.
You may not have any antibodies to that anymore, and you could safely take it.
Well, will I cause another reaction on the metabolic antibodies again?
No, not at all.
The reason why you would erodeously develop antibodies to a food is that if you have permeability in the gut,
or another reason for inflammation of the gut, but gut permeability, a leaky gut,
will open the barrier so that you will absorb things that you shouldn't have absorbed,
and then you would cause an immune reaction to that thing that should never be as a blood streamant
that you'd create antibodies against.
That's the reason why you create antibodies to food is because of a leaky gut.
So you have gut permeability for whatever reason, you know, you caused inflammation of the gut,
maybe parasites, maybe toxins that you're exposed to, whatever.
So you have damaged gut, probably the most common reason is antibiotics and other medications that cause inflammation of the gut.
Causes got permeability issues, and then you could develop antibodies to good foods,
like curcumin would be a good food, and now you have antibodies against that, and you can't eat it for a period of time.
So just because you reacted to it ten years ago doesn't mean you'll react to it today,
so I would just go slow and take caution and make every observation.
Next question, I often experience rumbling sounds in my stomach alone with cramps and pain in my sides.
I also pass gas frequently, and sometimes it is an unpleasant order.
What steps can I take to address this issue?
So all of these point to mal digestion.
So when we have mal digestion, we're not digesting food properly.
So it can be because from the other question, maybe I have antibodies to food,
and maybe I'm eating something that I have antibodies to.
Maybe I'm eating gluten that I have antibodies to, so it's causing this inflammatory response in my gut,
so I'm getting mal digestion.
So whenever we're getting a lot of pain, weird feelings in the gut, a lot of gas,
it is because of mal digestion.
Meaning the food is getting properly digested, and it's fermenting.
So number one, it can be food sensitivities.
So the only, for sure, way to know that is to do a food sensitivity panel,
and the only one that I ever recommend is the Cyrex 10 or rate 10.
But short of that, you could certainly do a food elimination,
like oh, it's trying to figure out, is it worse with certain foods?
And you can help figure that out.
The second cause of this, and these can be combined, understand.
The second cause of this is mal digestion, just because hyperchloridory,
a decreased hydrochloric acid in my stomach, and a decrease possibly going along with it,
of pancreatic enzymes.
So I'm not getting good enzymatic breakdown of my food in the stomach,
and mainly in the first part of the small intestine.
And I'm not getting good breakdown of my food in the stomach through HCl secretion.
So remember, hypochloridure or decreased stomach acid is the number one disease process,
if we want to call it that in the other planet.
You know, there's hands down, not even anything close to it.
It is very, very common.
Again, the reason is we damage our stomach cells.
Just like I said, we damage our gut cells, and it put leaky gut permeability.
We could damage our stomach cells.
And the primal cells are the stomach that secrete HCl are not doing their job,
and they're not secrete HCl well.
So we get food not to properly digest it in the stomach,
and go into the small intestine, fermenting, causing gas causing issues.
So the first step that I would take, this was me, I would increase my HCl
and digestive enzymes.
And we have a product that we've probably labeled that's called clear digest.
So clear digest, I would just be taking more of these with each meal.
You know, sometimes people have to get up to taking 5, 6, 7, 8, 9 with each meal.
That's typically not on a regular basis, but you need to get proper digestion,
and get things will be.
Doing coffee enemies can really help this too, because it's going to help calm things down,
and make sure you're eliminating as well.
Go also look at you guys have full access to the detoxification course,
the 7 phases of detoxification, look at that too,
that's going to give you some clues and things too.
But those are the main things that I would think about for that, bell digestion.
Next question, what is the best way to know if you have Hpylori?
Well, Hpylori can play into that last question of having a lot of gas in stomach issues too,
but Hpylori, number one, the reason why people get Hpylori
is because they have hypochloridria.
So, just so we talked about in the last question about hypochloridria,
is the number one, you know, malhealth issue worldwide,
Hpylori follows a close second because it's caused
from decrease hydrochloric acid production in the stomach.
In fact, according to the World Health Organization,
Hpylori infections are the number one bacterial infection worldwide.
Because it's so often silent, you know,
there's the majority of people have a silent Hpylori issue.
Hpylori as a major player for heart disease, heart diseases,
the number would cause a death in the United States.
It's a very common condition,
and typically they don't know that they haven't sometimes ever,
because usually you have a cord area, you have heart attack,
and you go into the hospital and they,
they're checking, it's blocked,
arteries, and they might do a bypass or put a stint in,
but they're never addressing the reason why.
I don't know if anybody's ever told me
that cardiologist suspects Hpylori infection
and he put me on, you know, whatever for Hpylori.
No, they don't ever do that.
So, best way to know if you have Hpylori,
there's many different tests.
There's called urea breath test that you breathe in,
you blow out the air through this tube,
and it measures the possibility of Hpylori in the gut.
But if you don't have Hpylori in the stomach any longer,
because it goes systemic and affects your arteries,
it affects all sorts of different things,
it will show a false negative.
There's a Hpylori test with a gut test,
so when we do a stool sample test on somebody,
it's quite often tests for Hpylori,
but if Hpylori is in present at that time,
or that stool sample, in the gut,
it's going to also show a false negative.
There's a blood test for Hpylori too,
but unless Hpylori is present in the blood,
which is very unlikely that it's going to be in the blood,
it's going to also be a false negative.
Because it doesn't stay in the blood,
you'll have sepsis, it goes into the tissues,
it affects the lining of the arteries,
it affects the endothelial cells,
it affects the muscles underneath the endothelial cells,
that's arteries, but it also goes systemic,
and it can affect all sorts of different organs.
Well, you're going to take a tissue sample
and measure for bacterial content.
So the best thing to do is just to treat as if,
if you have different symptoms,
I have said that I take Burberry on a regular basis,
not every day, to help with Hpylori,
because it is systemic,
and because it is a major,
number one cause of heart disease,
and it's a major cause of other cancer,
so you just can treat as if.
Now I have blog post on Hpylori,
he look back to Pylori is what it's called,
I have several blog posts about this,
how to kind of walk through that,
and to do self treatment.
Okay, questions from the chat.
What can you do to deal with tonsil stones?
I don't know the treatment for tonsil stones.
I apologize.
I don't know.
I've never treated anybody with tonsil stones,
so I don't know the treatment for that.
I'd have to look that up.
I don't have any answer for you.
I apologize.
Should cancer patients be taking perfect medos?
I can't remember off the top of my head,
but I think I've looked up perfect medos for other people,
and I didn't see a problem.
I didn't see that they were really high in glutamine.
I know there's a lot of fat supplements out there,
so a lot of people will see things on Instagram and Facebook,
and oh, this is the cure-all supplement I should get that too.
I must be just missing, you know,
I've just won the supplement shy of perfect health.
I can be careful of those things.
So protein powders that are high in glutamine,
I'm not a fan of, you know, amino acid.
What is it amino acid?
It is glutamine.
Is it amino acid?
So is it high in glutamine?
If it is that I would say no,
you have to look at the label of that.
That's why we use the protein design for the U.S.M.M.
because it's a lower glutamine protein powder
if you're going to take a protein powder.
Next question from the chat.
My breast lump caused nipple retraction.
It has also attached itself to the skin right above the nipple.
The lump is right there at the surface of the skin,
and it's hard as a rock,
at least what is attached to the skin
and can be easily felt by local practitioner, not a doctor,
so that the dead tissue can calcify,
and that may be a side that the lump is dead,
at least right there.
Is that true?
It can be, I don't know that if it will calcify
or just be fibrous tissue,
you would be able to tell the x-ray or MRI
would be able to show that if it's calcified.
And if it is, or just fibrous tissue,
that is a side that it's dead.
So yes, that is true.
Complete the question that says,
it feels like it could easily be pushed out through my skin.
I know that's going to be a mess if that happens.
If it does that, is it best to go ahead
and apply black sand to speed the process?
Will the nipple retraction complicate the process?
It can be a very complicated process,
and if it does break through the skin,
I've had many women that have used black sand on it
and it can, the real issue you have to watch for
is if it's going to bleed,
it tends to be a very, very long and seemingly endless process.
So we should talk if that does happen
because there's pros and cons to doing black sand
on a fairly large tumor.
Next question from the channel.
A friend of mine invited me to participate
in an online 21-day Soma breath work retreat.
Are you familiar with this?
I've looked at it a bit,
and I'm wondering if you thought
it would be something good for me to participate in.
I do not know what that is.
If it was me looking at that,
I would look at where the practitioners
are coming from from a spiritual standpoint.
Many breath work things that are out there
or from a physiological standpoint,
they're good, they're just helping you relax,
learning how to breathe properly,
it can help stimulate parasympathetic function.
So from a physiological standpoint,
it can be really good,
but you really do want to look at where they're coming
from a spiritual standpoint.
They're going to be talking you through
and focusing you on your thought process
in a way that isn't glorifying to God.
So I don't know where you are coming from.
So forgive me, but I come from a Christian perspective.
I won't do yoga.
Not because I think yoga is demonic per se,
but typically they're getting you to focus on something
that I don't want to be focusing on.
Could you do yoga from a Christian perspective?
Well, I think you probably could.
It's just a stretching procedure,
but it comes, you know,
it's where you're coming from with that.
So there's certain things you do want to be careful on,
and I would just investigate it and see what kind of information
that you could get.
I'm coming from the assumption that it's a breath work retreat
is teaching you breathing techniques for relaxation things.
So that's where I would say from a physiological standpoint,
there's nothing wrong with that.
Now I might be totally off base with that assumption,
but she is a yoga instructor as well.
And that's why I was cautious about participating.
Yeah, so that's something you're just going to have to pray about.
Maybe God wants you to do it for another reason to be a witness
to somebody there.
I don't know.
But personally, I would really want to have peace
about my decision in moving forward with something that
may not bring him glory.
Okay, any other questions?
So remember, we're not going to have a Zoom call next week.
So still feel free to get your questions in,
because I'll go back to the last question that I answered
for the following week.
Still get your questions in,
even though we won't have a Zoom call next week,
I'll get it on the next week's Zoom call.
All right, everybody, have a blessed day.
I'll be praying for you and we cherish your prayers.
And I'm sure everybody cherishes your prayers for them as well.
God bless everybody.
Bye-bye.